Brett: I don't know why I went like that. But that one made no sense for me.
Niko: I shot your legs out from under you.
Brett: Oh, did you?
*laughter*
Niko: How do you feel?
Brett: Uh..
*Laughter*
Brett: I'm glad that you guys called me considering that I busted my face open.
Cmike: Damn, dog.
Brett: I know, son.
Brett: Can't even see out of my left eye.
Jake: how's that doing? It's good.
Brett: It's not too bad.
Jake: Oh, dude you can't even tell.
Brett: Its a tiny little scar.
I spin a little bro,
This one's about, 72.
Niko: So Brett,
Niko: There's no one that takes a harder fall, in our videos than you, even we don't ask you to do it
You still do it you like commit really hard
But you always get up at the end
Brett: Thankfully,
Niko: So I was wondering if you could share with myself and everybody else watching how do you take a fall without hurting yourself?
Childish Wren: Oh my god, dude. Freaken flying Zombie
Niko: What is your secret? I know you grew up skateboarding doing lot of that?
But I want to learn a little about this this technique. How about you're just minding your own business one day
Bret:  Mhm
But you have this rare disease that causes you to turn to a ragdoll
once in a while,  and so spontaneously
You'll just ragdoll
Brett: basically my knees collapse. So you start with your knees collapsing
*Laughter*
(from the background) Cmike: What the fuck was that!?
Brett: Alright, Niko, you try.
Brett: Alright start with your knees, basically you keep your legs straight, and they just start with like a little bend
And once you felt that bend, you kind of just like...
Nick: How do you avoid hitting your head?
You just hold... look at Wren
You don't stiff your neck but you just keep it loose and just up a bit.
Niko: You don't put your hand out at all or anything like that
Brett: Well, I trust myself. I think that's a thing, too, is trust and knowing how your body would fall before you actually fall.
Niko: Just like...
Brett: There we go :)
*laughter*
-How do you feel?
-I feel great.
Jake: Yo, Niko
And his quest to make the perfect battleground video one of the characters has a really unique Spetsnaz helmet
It's a russian special Forces'
bulletproof helmet.
This is an old beekeepers mask is an airsoft helmet
And then I've got this visor from this janky Firemen's hat
Basically I'm going to put them all together, cover this with something, starts to work
I'm going to work with what we've got here and make a janky Spetsnaz helmet
Sam: So you probably already know this, but we are selling some incredible Peter 42 tees, designed by our friend, Drew
They're also in baseball tee style as well ,also uh good news.
We upgraded our shirts into this incredible nice durable thick Hanes t-shirt cotton
and It makes the print last a lot longer on these shirts
We're really excited to start carrying these for all our shirts
-So Brett, let's say you were minding your own business, and you get sniped.
-Okay? Where's the bullet hit
Yeah, okay. Let's do two hits. Let's do a shoulder hit, and you're like, "What!" and then head shot
Ok, shoulder, head
Oh, you're gonna shoot it, Nick
Niko: Dude, that's just like straight flat to the ground.
How did you land on your back like solid like that, without getting the wind knocked out of you?
Wren: This isn't soft either.
Brett: -I guess just trust myself enough to hit when I hit
just to kind of absorb it with my back too, now I'm using my lower back as well when I hit
Niko: You're staying pretty relaxed?
Brett: -Pretty relaxed, yeah.
So shoulder... and then head
but I'm not hitting like my... you know, I'm just hitting...
Wren: Did that even knock the wind out of you?
I breathe out right before I take the hit, just so it's like when I hit I don't keep that air in.
When you're rolling onto something is there a special technique to use like
how do you not keep just breaking your ankles and then collapsing to the ground
-When you roll?
-Yeah.
Roll
It's just using your back and your shoulder really. Like your shoulder goes in first and then your back rolls
Niko: Then, so you're spreading the impact out over a line of body and also making your mind to continue forwards
So a lot of energy doesn't actually get absorbed, it actually goes continuously.
If I was to try falling on my back like you did. Were you just kicked out and stay flat on your back? Train me
Brett: t's always good to have two shots for me
If you're hitting a shoulder, you're getting shot and you can still use that momentum from this to throw yourself backwards.
Niko: You're going down
well... :|
Let me give it a shot.
Jake: I don't know if you guys know this, but the Corridor Digital format of making viral short films isn't supported on YouTube at all.
I mean, yes a little bit
-Don't get me wrong...
-People enjoy them.
People enjoy 'em, we love making them, but it's not like our main source of revenue
We do it because we love it. Yeah, I'm going to drill some pilot holes.
This just comes off. Just like work on that separately.
My calculations. I need a T25.
-Of course it's not here. Why would it be here it belongs?
-Why are these nails right here by the way?
So you can hang sh*t. Don't get me wrong. I love everybody here, but sometimes working here is like working with a bunch of teenagers.
Bada-bing, all right, we're in business!
Now, I'll put the lining back in and then I will work on a piece to cover this so that you get a solid...
...plate.
Are you ready?
How do you feel?
I land on my side more than on my back. I kind of chickened out on the back hit
Nope, chickened out
Right now, you're landing on like a 45 degree angle and angled down, where the trick is you actually got to land flat.
Wren: That was a lot better
Niko: I still put my hands down
Wren: But you landed flat this time
Niko: But I didn't quite land on my shoulders like Brett instructed me to...But I feel okay.
try not to stop myself my hands
That doesn't do anything. Just makes the fall look shitty
Wren: I'm gonna be sniped.
Brett: What's your method?
Wren: Wing it.
Brett: I always treat. It like a light punch you know, like...
I keep my body little loose too, so you're able to do that kind of stuff, so
Then I use this as you push back
you know
Wrennny boi: Alright, is there a sniper around?
Brett: How do you feel?
Wren:
I don't feel good at all.
Niko: You like, didn't relax at all.
Wren: I didn't, I was like so tensed. That was like the worst thing to do
I got to do that again
Can never do that! I think it's, I didn't exhale when I crashed,
my whole body just-
Brett: Are you breathing or are you tense?
Wren: I was tensed.
(Niko talking to Wren in the background.)
Wren: Was I?
I gotta, I gotta arch my back more.
Brett: Not, not too much like that.
You'll probably brake something. Just slight, you know, like just very light
Niko: Sam, you wanna snipe Wren?
Wren: See, I'm laying on my right side rather than flat on my back
(Rambunctious boys...)
I supposed thats as far as i get.
every-mans kip, check this out
Oh my God these guys did a number on this blade dude
We're gonna have to replace that blade. every time I go to find something
What would you leave for now?
Just a pencil that I keep in here.
There's a pencil by your foot.
This isn't it, but, it will do
That's right goes
check this out
Ready? my hands empty. I go under the table...
and pick up...
Dude ya, that's where the glue goes.
I might sound like I'm just complaining, which I kind of am....
having a clean workshop where...
it's not, yeah
It's all of these tools are really expensive. if you don't really understand like like this is a  $120 power drill
, it's like a $100 jigsaw. You have thousands of dollars worth of equipment in here
You know I've tried multiple different ways
To get people to pay more attention to it, but at least we got the camera room a little bit more figured out
Look, in the time when the glue gun to gonna heat up. I bet you I can clean up half of this workshop
yeah, we film all these shirts pushers on one day and guess what. You got one day left to get these Peter 42 shirts as well.
So if you haven't gotten one yet, or interested, check out corridordigital.com/store
We're also selling these in an incredible baseball tee style as well and screen printed so check them out before they're gone
Dude, Talk about walls. When you're like running into a walls.
ok, all right. Let's create situations. I think situations help me better to...
So you guys come around the corner, and Niko stops here and blasts zombie
That's pursuing him
my name is Blanche Masterson
A trucker turned survivor when the world was infected, but it didn't affect me cuz I was in my truck now
I've been researching with gas station for food
Hey man, you okay?
oh
Dude, are you all right? Brett?
I'm good son.
Dude there's a flop in the end, so good.
Did I do this?
No.
Ok.
Having something react off of when doing stunts, it's like, for me,
It's that extra like initiative to actually do it.
So I notice, like, when you came at the wall
You didn't just hit the wall you sold the stunt on how hard you flown everything up to the wall, so it's like
You snapped your hair back and snapped your arms
You made it look like you're basically struck by lightning flop down to the ground
and when you hit the ground I also notice that
You do the kind of same thing, I guess, struck by lightning
Again, when you hit the ground you sold the impact, but flicking everything again
Yeah, that was definitely two impacts so you can definitely act off of it like especially when I hit the ground
I'm able to kind of, you know, do an extra roll out of it
You know, like land on my face or something
So I feel like I should take what I learned to be the zombie this time
Ok, I'm down to shoot you
There's half of the Table there's half the workshop
Glue gun's to not even hot yet
Someone is gonna f**king saw their hands off this thing I know it
Carbon fiber
Glue guns hot there's still some spray paint on the ground. I'll admit. How long did that take five minutes?
cool part one
Sweet
I got the grand big globs of the greasy grammy
I got the greasy grammy go for guts, and my grammy, don't get your grandma guts on my grammy
pretty good
Hey man, you good?
That's actually a really good one. It was, really. How does that feel
Feel Fine. I just kind of tried to explode everything before I hit the wall and then
Actually I push off the wall off my hand
I flee myself off it and then I spin down to the ground
oh good
So what I think could really sell is that impact of the bullet
Yeah, I didn't you the first one very well. My hit on the ground was good
But my first bullet impact wasn't any good. I basically like just getting ready for this move and like did that
Over the two stage there
Yeah, all the different techniques. Alright, Brett
Well, hopefully you save some people some injury hopefully if they slip on ice like something like that, they'll probably like,
Just character thats commit thats stroked by lighting bult
no Sim card, so
Peter has been using this Sony phone since his phone broke.
And  I just found buried away in the cable box in the equipment room
A broken phone, and these are our phones that we have here.
I thought peter broken it and hidden
It was not him, it was not peter, but someone broke
One of the studio phone and hid it in the cable box
What we have a mystery
We have a investigation alright
if fingerprints going on
Is actually spotless. when I found it. They wiped it
really. Did they wiped it down
Its professional
Dude get your hat and magnifying glass. We got a mystery to solve, Peter